Cheryl Burke reveals her least favorite
Dancing with the Stars partner ever
dancing the Rumba ion's earring and his
partner Cheryl Burke
yes it's I Anna's earring the star makes
the confession on the allegedly podcast
with Theo von and Matt Weiss this week
the fact that his name's not Ian
and his eyen makes me want to throw up I
agree Cheryl says she couldn't stand
spending eight to ten hours a day with
the sharknado actor it made me want to
slit my wrists yeah there you go like
hey exact sounds like crying its
executives it was like kids or anybody's
just forces just like eliminate us like
we can't we can't do that now Cheryl is
apologizing for those comments tweeting
that the slit my wrists line was
insensitive but she's not apologizing
for calling ayan out they made it to the
top four in season four and luckily he
didn't turn the dancer off from the show
she lasted 14 more seasons and still
loves the competition so it's like you
know we're still gonna always be a
family um I do miss it I just you know
maybe one day they'll ask me to be like
a guest judge or like no you know I
would love to be a part of it in some
capacity